let's add a new style sheet and a media
query that applies only when the
viewport is wider than 500 pixels I'll
add new linked CSS file with the media
attribute and I'll set the value to
screen and min width 500 pixels so that
it's only applied when this screen is
over 500 pixels you may see references
to other media types but ignore them
media types like handheld projected or
embossed never really gained any
traction and don't do anything just
stick with screen and print if you think
your users are gonna want to print your
page I'll take a look at the style sheet
that gets applied and see that it
changes the background color to blue all
right I'll reload the page in the
browser notice that the background
remains white but as I start to resize
it once it hits that 500 pixel
breakpoint the screen turns blue because
the media queries been matched